So we're going to be talking about uh some
new world records uh going 23% beyond the
Riemann Hypothesis. So the Riemann Hypothesis is
one of the great problems in mathematics with
a million dollar prize if you solve it. But
before I get ahead of myself, let's just talk
about our favorite numbers - the primes. So the
sequence begins just with 2, 3, 5, 7, 11, 13, 17, 19,
23 and so on. So we know by Euclid the sequence of
primes goes on forever but famously the primes
are really known for being mysterious and having
a lot of complexity so maybe a simpler thing we could
look at is just the last digit. So consider just
lopping off the other digits and just considering
the ones at the end. So it starts off the same; for
the single digit primes 2, 3, 5, 7 and once we get to
11 we just keep the 1 at the end. 13 we just keep
the 3 at the end, 17 we just keep the 7 at
the end and so on. So Brady I'm not so fast writing
all these numbers down, especially if they go on
forever, maybe with some help of a computer maybe
we can speed up this process. Let's just consider
looking at the list of prime numbers up to 100. So
it starts off as before - 2, 3, 5, 7 - but then it goes up
to 97, so that's the largest prime up to 100. So we
look at the last digit of these primes, it starts
off again 2, 3, 5, 7 - but then at the end when we're
throwing off we get 89 becomes a 9, 97 becomes a
7. The advantage of a computer here is that we can
just change one character and instead of looking
at primes up to 100 we could look up primes
to 500 and just generates that list uh pretty
readily. And if we do the same thing, just looking
at the last digit, we get this uh longer table of
data. As a mathematician once you see a table of
data your ears perk up and you ask uh you know are
there any patterns in this data? Um so Brady maybe
if we stare at this table maybe some thoughtsare
going to emerge; which numbers occur frequently?
Are there any numbers that don't occur? You see
anything?
- (Brady: There are no even numbers except for the2 at the start.)
- And that's because?
(It would bedivisible by 2.)
- Right right. So if a number ends
in a 2, ends in an even number, then the whole
number itself is even. By a similar argument, maybe
a bit more subtle, there are no 5s in this list
after the the first 5 because if a number ends
in a 5 then the whole number itself has to be
divisible by 5.
- (Same for 0?)
- Yeah so 0 is a double whammy; it hits us both with being even
and also being a multiple of 5. So what we've
just shown here by this argument is that we only
have a few options here for the digits that can
appear in this list. So so after the single digit
numbers eventually it's either going to be a 1
or a 3 or a 7 or a 9. And here the point that
you've just figured out is that the number 10, the
base is equal to 2 times 5 so we've just eliminated
all the digits that have a 2 in it or a 5 in it.
- (Okay so we've got these four numbers; the next)
(question I guess people ask is which are mostcommon?)
- Yeah I mean that's that's the that's the
question. So a natural thing to do is to maybe plot
these numbers on a histogram; so let's look at the
numbers up to 100 and look at the digits. So as we
said before there's going to be only one instance
of a 2 in this, and we put them into bins, say one
instance of a 2. Similarly there's only one
instance of a 5 and all the other numbers up to
100 are either going to have a 1, a 3, a 7 or a
9. One of the great advantages of a computer is you
can just change one character again and generate
a lot more data. So if we look at numbers up to 1,000
we can get these bar charts where these
single entries are getting slimmer and slimmer
and these other four bars are getting taller and
taller. And maybe if we go very far, let's say we
go out to a million, we look at the primes up to
a million and look at their last digit there's
just a tiny sliver corresponding to 2; a tiny
sliver corresponding to 5 and then all these
other four options seems to be almost the same
height. So roughly uh a 25% chance of getting a
1 as a last digit of a prime, same for 3,
same for 7, same for 9. So there's an equal
chance to get any of these four options. That is no
coincidence Brady, this is the prime number theorem
in action. We've been playing this game, this fun
little game, uh looking at the last digit, but
really we've been using the fact that we have
you know 10 fingers on our hands; but we can look
at other bases. You know, for example computers work
in base 2, all their uh data stored with 1s and
0s, so we we can play the same game uh looking
at the last digit uh in other bases. Let's just
change one line of code and now uh maybe we get
something uh a bit less interesting here so we get
uh our first uh entry is a 0 corresponding to
the prime 2 and then all the other primes have
their last digit 1 in binary. So this just means
that all the primes after 2 are odd. Maybe this
wasn't as interesting but the next interesting
thing we could look at is maybe uh base 3 so
we just increase by one and we look at the prime
written in ternary and just extract the last digit.
So as before we just have a 0 corresponding
in this case to the number 3 itself but all
the other options for the primes are going to be
either a 1 or a 2 for their last digit in ternary.
And so this really again suggests, why don't we
play the same game, now look in base 3, maybe
the numbers up to 1,000 - there's going to be
one number, namely 3, that has the last digit 0 but
all other numbers are either going to have a 1
or a 2. And again these are very much dominating.
Maybe if we go up to a million again we see that
the heights of these two options - almost 50/50
split. And again this is no coincidence Brady. So
you could pick your favorite base, I don't know
say 101, uh and you can have play a similar game:
you look at all the last digits of primes uh in
base 101 let's say numbers up to 5 million and you
can get a nice uh roughly uniform distribution. And
maybe there's a bit of wiggle room at the top but
as the numbers get larger and larger the wiggles
start to to to damp out and you get this result.
So Brady this is uh kind of a a fun illustration of
one of the deep results in mathematics, the prime
number theorem. So people on the channel may be
familiar, in this case the prime number theorem for
arithmetic progressions; which says the last digit
of a prime in any base you pick eventually tends
to have an even chance. And that's of course unless
there is some clear reason why there's a violation.
So in the case of an even digit; so as long as
the digit has no shared factors with the base
we expect an even spread across all options. So
maybe to be a bit more precise as a mathematician
I just want to introduce some math notation: pi
of x here is the number of primes up to x and the
more precise count that we are interested in is
looking at the number of primes up to x that have
last digit a in base b.
- (Pi has nothing to do withpi pi?)
- Right. So this is one of those things where
mathematicians uh are overloaded with notation
at any time and maybe at some point in 1700s
people decided you know this was a a convenient
letter to to use for primes; the same uh the same
consonant uh, but yeah it's kind of a stretch.
Sothis is the number primes up to x that have last
digit equal to a and this is written in base b.
The result of the prime number theorem tells us
in a more precise way that each of these options
for digits occur with roughly equal frequency. So
for any choice of digit and base, pi of x b comma a
we have this approximate relation that this count
is asymptotic to pi of x over phi of b. So here phi
of b is the Euler phi function which just counts;
so phi of b is just counting the number of possible
digits we can use. So the number of digits, a, that
have no uh shared factors with b. So in maybe
the mathematical lingo we say that the gcd, the
greatest common divisor, of a and b is equal to
1. Yeah so this is a a nice piece of mathematics
that holds eventually so as x gets larger. But a
natural question Brady is maybe you're a little
bit impatient and you want to know, you know, how
long do I have to wait uh for this to kick in and
those bars start to even out?
- (I mean that depends
how you define even out as well doesn't it?)
Right Imean so so there are certainly very technical- like
various levels of technicality how you want to be
precise; but morally speaking all we want to know
is how long do we have to go along the number line
to really start to see uh these numbers evening
out. But we've now just with this uh seemingly
innocuous question, really gotten thrown in the
deep end. Think of you know people playing around
on the shore at the beach, maybe you go snorkeling
and around some coral, but somehow you took a deep
dive and somehow you're now at the bottom of
the Marianas trench, you're at the deepest of
the deep in mathematics - we've now gotten to the
Riemann Hypothesis. Okay so I really want to narrow in
on this this key relationship in the prime number
theorem which is saying the digits really even out
in their distribution among the primes, so let's
give this a start here. So the Riemann Hypothesis
really has to do with answering the how soon
question about star. So the Riemann Hypothesis
tells us that star will hold once we get roughly
speaking uh x being larger than the base squared.
So this is a key threshold; so in other words the
Riemann hypothesis - or more precisely the generalized
Riemann hypothesis - says that this relationship star
holds for bases b that are less than the square root
of x, as x tends to infinity. In other words the prime
number theorem is telling us a a nice relationship
that exists among primes for any base b we we
choose; maybe 10, maybe 3, maybe 101. But the
Riemann hypothesis is really telling us that we can get
the same phenomenon occurring even if we allow the
size of our base to grow moderately with x, with
the size of the numbers.
- (I've made videos about)
(the Riemann hypothesis before - and I don't pretend to
understand it - but I've seen graphs and critical)
(strips and and all these different numbers but
I've never heard anything about the last digits of)
(numbers or bases)
- Right. I mean there are many ways to
approach this uh great trench of the Riemann hypothesis.
So one of the kind of links with uh the other for-
perhaps more standard technical formulation of
the Riemann hypothesis has to do uh with the zeros
of the Riemann-Zeta function so-called and their
placement on so-called the critical line of 1/2.
And it is no coincidence that the critical line of
1/2 is the same constant of 1/2 occurring in this
threshold of the square root of x. So these are- these
two relationships are intimately linked in thisway.
But I- I think this is a I guess a
more down to Earth way to kind of talk about the
Riemann hypothesis.
- (Okay)
- So obviously the Riemann
hypothesis is one of these kind of white whales
of mathematics that is still unsolved today. But
amazingly in the 1960s mathematicians were able
to prove an average version of this result.
Bombieriand Vinogradov in 1965 they were able to show that
this relationship star holds for almost all bases
b. I'm meaning that this relationship holds for
over 99.9% of b's up to this Riemann hypothesis
range - square root of x. When I first heard about this
result in uh my first year of uh grad school I
thought it was- I mean absolutely stunning because
uh I I somehow felt like the Riemann hypothesis was
you know somehow unobtainable and no one's
really been able to say anything about it; and so
I feel when I first learned about it I was almost
feeling like uh someone's keeping this from me. So
I I really feel someone should have told me about
this earlier. And the way I like to think about
this result, this over 99% result, maybe an analogy
with with cleaning cleaning tools. You know if you
want to clean around the house, maybe you want to
sanitize your hands, you get Purell. Or if you uh want
wanted to clean your countertop you get Lysol.
It says on the label if you read it, cleans over
99% of germs right. So this is their real real
selling point; and this is because you know for
work around the house 99% of germs is really more
than okay. And it's only really in kind of extreme
ideal circumstances like being a hospital, in a
hospital where you need a a full sterile room,
uh to get that 100%. And so by the same token as
mathematicians uh the Riemann hypothesis is really
this kind of Ideal scenario uh getting a full
result that we want to hold but for most practical
purposes as a mathematician, in my research, the
Bombieri-Vinogradov theorem is this completely adequate
substitute uh for application- for a lot ofapplications.
- (I'm not having that Jared.)
(I'm not having that. Because in the infinite- because
in the infinite world of numbers 99% isn't)
(that much. Like there's still a lot of numbers that
it doesn't work for.)
- That is definitely true and
obviously this is part of the conceptual reason
why we want to have a complete understanding;
but in one of the kind of facets of the Riemann
hypothesis is that people have proven many
results uh with the initial caveat 'assume the Riemann
hypothesis then..' And there were many results in the
1960s that went from a conditional uh hypothesis
to uh complete ironclad theorem once this uh
result came out; and it turns out in some technical
settings it is enough to just know this 99%
version to get the desired end goal if you were
using the Riemann hypothesis implicitly in your work.
(But if they found uh a power, an exponent, where
Fermat'sLast Theorem broke; there was like one number out)
(there where Andrew Wiles- this building wouldn't be
named after Andrew Wiles)
- Yeah yeah. So you know as a
mathematician you really want to get that complete
understanding and exceptional cases can really uh
be important, and so this also ties in with uh
previous uh things on the channel about Siegel
zeros which are these potential real uh monsters
is uh trying to thwart the Riemann hypothesis. Before
this I mean I just want to emphasize how kind of
amazing I find this, because before this result no
one really knew anything. Like you couldn't- uh you
couldn't really say uh much at all, uh and really
taking the statistical perspective uh has really
been leading to a flourishing in in mathematical
research. So this is well not again the the ideal
scenario but for most practical purposes as
a working mathematician around the house uh this
this is really kind of an important uh tool in the toolkit.
- (Okay I believe you)
- So now we get- now we
get to the real uh the real beans. Once presented with
this result, and if we're if we're only looking at
some of the bases and not all, a question comes up,
another question. We asked how soon? But if we're
only looking at some of the bases can we go even
sooner? Can we get a rate of convergence faster
than what the Riemann hypothesis is predicting?
So can we get uh bases b that are beyond this
square root x barrier? So in other words Brady
I'm asking to go beyond the Riemann hypothesis.
It wasuh remarkable results in the 1980s that actually
first uh made a proof of concept showing we havethis-
- (What is x again? Remind me what x actually is?)
So x is the size of the numbers- the size of the
primes were going up to. So sometimes it was like
100, sometimes 1,000 or a million. And this
gets these- these uh bar charts get more and more
refined as as x gets larger. But really the the
meat and potatoes of the question is how soon?
Can we go even sooner?
- (That's how soon they start
evening? But how are you defining evening?)
Yeah so I mean uh you can measure - and for example look
at the difference between uh the desired quantity
and then the the expected average. And then- so you
know in statistics you have the concept of a a
mean or kind of the average of a distribution and
then also the variance or the standard deviation.
And so you can ask more technical questions about
looking at the standard deviation, this is really
what the Riemann hypothesis is all about. So this
is kind of the second order question about the
distribution of primes. So we have this of course
uh result from 1965 which gets this uh Riemann
hypothesis on average bound. But this was improved
remarkably in the 1980s, getting exponents up to x
to the 0.571. So the way to interpret this Brady,
this breakthrough, is we went 15% beyond the
Riemann hypothesis. And this result really for almost 40
years was the state-of-the-art going beyond the
Riemann hypothesis until about two years ago where James
Maynard uh actually extended this result. So in
2021 he found that there were some bases that
you could take all the way up to x the 0.60. So
in other words we can go up to 20% beyond the
Riemann hypothesis. So after almost a four decade
uh hiatus uh there's been progress on the problem
by James Mayard who- fans of the channel.
- (He's up-)
(He's up there somewhere! His office is up there. We
should have got him in here)
- Yeah and so today I'm
happy to say that we can get even further up to
b up to 0.617 - in other words we can go 23% beyond
the Riemann hypothesis.
- (What does that mean?)
- So this means that there are some bases b of up to this
size going beyond the Riemann hypothesis range, for
which the primes in that base have their digits
being kind of nicely uh distributed as we would
expect. So we only have to wait a shorter amount
of time, 23% uh less time than we would expect from
the Riemann hypothesis-
- (Before they start flattening out)
Before they- so so this is kind of a savings of time uh
in one sense; in other words we can take more bases
and this result is holding for for more uh base bexpansions.
- (Do we know what any of these bases are?)
Uh so that's one of uh maybe the kind of aspects
of this more statistical approach is that we're
looking at families of numbers. And so one of the
insights, all all the way going back to the
Bombieri-Vinogradov theorem, is that if you look at collections
of numbers or families of numbers together you
can gain additional insights that might not
be as apparent from looking at an individual
number. So we can't necessarily pinpoint an exact
b that this holds but we can still have a family
uh that's of a larger size. And again maybe in in
an ideal scenario we can try to prove the Riemann
hypothesis and we can prove these nice results for
every single b; but in many practical applications
these kinds of results are are very useful. We'd
actually expect this to hold for all the bases
but that's again beyond what- so even if you prove
the Riemann hypothesis this would be a question yet
beyond what we can do there. So that's maybe far
off in the distance for future generations to
think about. But at least from a statistical point
of view this is uh I feel making good progress.
(We know that it holds for base 2, 3, 4)
- Yeahso for any- for any individual fixed number, already
the prime number theorem is telling us that we get
this nice convergence. But it's only when the bases
are allowed to grow moderately um we we want to be
able to quantify that rate of growth. So uh already
we know even by the Siegel–Walfisz theorem which
was proven over about 100 years ago we can allow
the base to grow logarithmically or very very
slowly with x and not run into trouble, but really
you you have to assume these very heavyweight
conjectures like the Riemann hypothesis if you
want an individual b to be growing uh like up to
the square root of x. These kinds of results uh I feel
have a very uh beautiful aspect where they connect
so that the proof ideas that go into them connect
a wide range of ideas across maybe seemingly
disparate areas of math. So on the one hand uh some
ideas that go into this relate to modular forms,
these kind of exotic objects uh that actually
ended up playing a crucial role for example in
Fermat's last theorem proven by Andrew Wiles and has led
to the Langlands programs. Um on the other hand
uh it uses results from algebra geometry; uh more
specifically the the Weil bound and the Deligne bound,
from the so-called Riemann hypothesis for curves
over finite fields uh which is itself another
story for another time. But I just want to convey
the sense that a lot of- uh there's a confluence
of a lot of ideas coming together just to uh make
progress on understanding the distribution of
just the primes. And as a just a last shout out,
so I wanted to say that there seems to be a kind
of nice revival in this field of studying these
questions uh in the last maybe decade where there
before had been something something of a lull;
I just wanted to shout out some people, who are
who have been uh doing some interesting work and
we've been having a nice discussion. So it's really
good to see this uh flourishing of this this
subject.
...100. Between 1 and 1,000, between 1
and 1 million. For any uh n between one and n using
his zeta function. Which is absolutely astonishing
because if you think about zeta function, something
has to do with complex numbers and with analytic
continuation and so on and so forth. So it's a
particular branch of mathematics which is called
complex analysis. But prime numbers live in a
different branch of mathematics.
- It tells us things
we already suspect because we sort of believe the
Riemann hypothesis is true but there are things we can't
prove. So for example how many primes are there
up to a trillion? We have a formula for that that
we believe is true but we can only prove that
formula if we know the Riemann hypothesis is true.